bonjour alors je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais une élection
présidentielle qui arrive bientôt sauf
si vous regardez cette vidéo en 2025
auquel cas laissez moi vous rappeler que
je tourne actuellement le 20 mars 2022
et que donc on a le premier tour des
élections présidentielles qui arrivent
dans tout pile 22 jours alors comme
d'habitude on est abreuvé d'information
de sondages de débats d'inquiétude et il
ya une question qui revient à chaque
fois c'est mais pourquoi les gens ne
votent pas davantage c'est vrai que sur
longue période il ya une part de plus en
plus importante de la population qui ne
va pas voter les présidentielles restent
le suffrage qui rassemble plus
d'électeurs avec seulement 22 23 %
d'abstention au premier tour des
dernières présidentielles mais c'est
surtout pour les régionales de 2021
qu'on a explosé notre record personnel
avec 66 72 % d'abstention et sur les
législatives on n'est pas mal non plus
avec une abstention qui a plus que
doublé entre 1958 et 2017 alors déjà
avant de commencer quoi que ce soit
mettons-nous bien d'accord sur les
termes comment on compte la
participation ou l'abstention électorale
donc je vais illustrer sa avec les
chiffres de 2010 est avec des chiffres
de l'insee pour la population française
et des chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur pour la participation
électorale en 2017 la population
française c'est 66 millions sept cent
soixante quatorze mille quatre cent
quatre-vingt deux personnes attention
c'est précis bon là dessus il faut
enlever tout ce qu'on pas l'âge de voter
tous euros moins de 18 ans les enfants
les parasites tout ça ça nous donne donc
potentiellement 52 millions 300 8326
électeurs potentiels mais bon faut déjà
voir que sur ce cheptel là il y en a
déjà environ 10% qui sont pas inscrits
sur les listes électorales parce que
quand on prend le nombre d'inscrits on
tombe à 40 7 millions 580 à 1118
personnes et donc c'est sur ces
personnes inscrites sur les listes qu'on
calcule le taux d'abstention c'est à
dire que sur ses 47 millions cinq cent
mille personnes il y en a 22 23 % qui
sont pas allés voter et 77 77 % qui sont
allés voter après sur ses 77 points 77 %
de votants ce qui fait 37 millions 3546
personnes on distingue les votes blancs
1,78 pour cent les votes nuls c'est
quand on vote pour un candidat tout
pourri donc ça c'est 0 77% et enfin les
votes exprimés 97 points 45% soit 36
millions 58 1813 voix un vote exprimé
c'est donc juste un bulletin qui va
effectivement monté pour l'un des
candidats présents et donc après tout ça
on compte les pourcentages pour chaque
candidat du coup quand emmanuel macron
arrive en tête du premier tour avec 24 0
1% des voix c'est 24% des votes exprimés
si on compte les votes blancs et nuls il
tombe à 23 4 % des votants si on compte
l'abstention il a reçu 18,19 % des
inscrits et si on compte toute la
population en âge de voter ce n'est plus
que 16 5% des français de plus de 18 ans
qui ont effectivement voté pour lui au
premier tour alors si je vous dis tout
ça c'est pas juste pour le plaisir de
faire des statistiques même si on va pas
se mentir ça fait plaisir quand même
mais c'est pour illustrer le fait que
l'abstention et plus encore la main
l'inscription ça peut entamer
considérablement la légitimité
démocratique du vainqueur d'une élection
et sur cette question la plupart des
commentateurs politiques se demande pas
pourquoi on a besoin de plus en plus
pourquoi les jeunes ne s'intéressent
plus à la politique etc etc mais
aujourd'hui justement je vais essayer de
retourner un peu la question en arrêtant
de me demander pourquoi les gens ne vont
pas voter mais décide plutôt d'expliquer
mais en fait pourquoi on vote
[Musique]
alors quand je demande pourquoi on vote
ne me répondez pas un peu c'est pour
élire un candidat non la question que je
posais les plus sociologique j'essaie de
comprendre les comportements des acteurs
sociaux et donc je me demande qu'est-ce
qui explique qu'un individu puisse faire
la démarche de se lever 1 dimanche pour
se rendre dans son ancienne école
primaire faire la queue potentiellement
pendant pas mal de temps pour aller
déposer une enveloppe dans une urne au
lieu simplement je ne sais pas d'aller
faire une balade en forêt ou un brunch
avec ses copains cette question c'est
l'économiste anthony donne ce qui se
l'est posée en 1957 dans son ouvrage un
economics terry of democracy qu'on peut
traduire par une théorie économique de
la démocratie ouais je suis pas sûr vous
avez vraiment besoin de moi sur ce coup
là dans ce livre dense essaye
d'expliquer le comportement des
électeurs en raisonnant comme un
économiste c'est à dire en utilisant la
théorie du choix rationnel
il part donc du principe qu'on raisonne
tous comme ce qu'on appelle des homo
economicus c'est à dire qu'on prend
toutes nos décisions de manière
parfaitement rationnel pour maximiser
notre satisfaction la satisfaction les
économistes appellent ça l'utilité par
exemple si j'ai le choix entre un gâteau
au chocolat qui m'apporte une utilité
disons de 10 et une tarte au citron qui
m'apporte une utilité de 15 alors je
choisis la tarte au citron évidemment
mais si celle ci est plus cher alors il
faut que je compare la différence de
satisfaction entre les deux et que je
vois si elle est inférieure ou
supérieure à la perte de satisfaction
que vam provoqué la différence de prix
en gros je fais un calcul coût avantage
en me demandant si les cinq d'utilité
gagné par la tarte au citron valent plus
pour moi que les deux europe sur coup si
oui mais je prends la tarte au citron
sinon bah je reste sur le gâteau au
chocolat alors cette façon rationnelle
de poser les calculs peut paraître très
froide et robotique à l'image de
monsieur spock toujours rationnels au
risque d'être borné
mais ce n'est pas non plus un mode de
raisonnement complètement absurde et ça
le gros avantage pour les économistes de
leur permettre de modéliser les
comportements humains dans des gros dell
avec des baies l'équation de calcul coût
avantage bon et justement la conclusion
de downs c'est que m personne ne devrait
normalement aller voter parce que le
calcul coût avantage est clairement en
défaveur du vote et oui parce que aller
voter c'est des coups qui sont en fait
assez important déjà il faut s'informer
donc lire des programmes ça prend du
temps il faut se lever le dimanche
patienter donc ça je l' ai déjà dit pour
des gains qui sont ou fait quasiment
nulles car notre voix n'aura
statistiquement aucun effet dans le
choix final de l'élection donne va même
plus loin en soulignant que la
possibilité pour chaque électeur
d'affecter le résultat obtenu est
inférieure à celle d'être tué on se
déplaçant pour voter c'est donc très
difficile d'expliquer l'acte de vote par
la dimension seulement rationnelle et
individuelles la seule situation où ils
imaginent qu'ils seraient éventuellement
un peu rationnel d'aller voter c'est
quand les scores sont très serrés et que
du coup bas notre vote il a des chances
d'être décisif pour faire pencher la
majorité d'un côté ou de l'autre alors
par la suite la réflexion de johns elle
va être formalisée mathématiquement par
l'économiste gordon tullock qui va
mettre au point l'équation suivante est
régal pb - ses airs correspond ou bien
inspirés que l'individu obtient quand il
choisit de voter plutôt que de
s'abstenir donc le fait d'aller voter pc
la probabilité que son vote soit décisif
baisser le bénéfice qu'ils résultent de
l'élection du candidat donc à quel point
on préfère le candidat plutôt qu'un
autre et c c'est le coup d'aller voter
donc le coût d'information de
déplacement le coup de pertes de temps
et aussi le coût d'opportunité parce que
le temps que je passe pour faire tout ça
je le passe pas faire autre chose qui
pourrait être plus fun
du coup pour aller voter il faut que air
soit positif sinon c'est que ça vaut pas
le coup donc pour ça il faut que p x b
soit supérieure à ces mais comme par
définition paix a une valeur très très
proche de zéro puisque par définition on
a quand même très très peu de chances
d'être décisive avec notre vote et dans
le modèle prédit une participation quasi
nul bon donc on voit bien que le modèle
ne marche pas sinon c'est pas 23 mai 99
% d'abstention qu'on aurait à chaque
élection mais on peut voir qu'il y a
quand même un véritable effet de la
variable p1 qui étudie le caractère
décisif ou non du vote c'est pour ça que
en général on a plus de participation au
second tour parce que les scores
justement sont plus serré au second tour
qu'au premier et les votes sont vus
comme plus décisif parce que ben il faut
départager en score un peu serré on voit
aussi que les gens vont moins voté quand
l'élection est vue comme jouée d'avancé
c'était le cas par exemple au premier
tour des présidentielles de 2002 où on a
connu 28 4 % d'abstention entre
parenthèses c'est le taux le plus élevé
jamais vu au premier tour d'une
présidentielle en france et ça c'est
parce que tout le monde était persuadé
que lionel jospin était qualifié
d'office pour le second tour comme quoi
parfois les impressions bien sûr il y a
plein de critiques à faire sur le modèle
de l'électeur rationnelle de down mais
je trouve intéressant sa manière en fait
d'inverser la perspective est d'arrêter
de considérer que valent les
abstentionnistes sont ceux qui ont un
comportement étonnant qu'il s'agirait d'
expliquer et de montrer au contraire que
ne pas voter peut aussi être interprétée
comme le comportement le plus rationnel
mais du coup ci c'est rationnel de
s'abstenir
comment on explique qui est quand même
des gens qui votent en fait il y a
beaucoup de façons d'expliquer le fait
d'aller voter par militantisme par
habitude par colère ou par conviction et
on voit que dans toutes ces raisons on
s'éloigne du comportement parfaitement
rationnel tel qu'il est envisagé par les
économistes par respect
pour revenir un peu à de la sociologie
on peut reprendre la typologie des
différentes formes d'action de max weber
l'idée de webber c'est qu' aucune action
humaine n'est complètement inexplicable
même quand les gens font des choses qui
nous paraissent farfelu de prime abord
ou même irrationnel on peut toujours
l'expliqué d'une façon qui fait sens
pour l'acteur en question et liste donc
quatre types d'actions qui peuvent
expliquer les comportements humains on
l'a d'abord l'action affective puis
l'action traditionnelle l'action
rationnelle en valeur et enfin l'action
rationnelle ans finalité alors l'action
affective c'est quand on agit sous le
coup de l'émotion un canton gifle
quelqu'un par colère par exemple dans le
cas du vote on peut prendre l'exemple
justement là du deuxième tour des
présidentielles de 2002 où les électeurs
ont été profondément choqués que jean
marie le pen accèdent au second tour ce
qui explique la forte baisse de
l'abstention par rapport au premier on
aurait pu s'attendre à l'effet inverse 1
on aurait pu croire que une partie
importante de l'électorat de gauche
s'abstiennent faute de candidat et je
pense que la remobilisation de
l'électorat s'explique principalement
par la réaction émotionnelle qui a
suscité le front national à l'époque
deuxièmement on à l'action
traditionnelle c'est l'action qu'on fait
quand on ne réfléchit pas vraiment en
fait qu'on continue à faire quelque
chose parce que on a toujours fait comme
ça jouer puis jean lacouture fait comme
ça dans le cas du vote on sait que bas
le vote c'est aussi une routine une
habitude démocratique qui a été
ritualisé il ya beaucoup de gens qui
votent parce que dans leur famille on a
toujours voté c'est un peu comme un
devoir démocratique
c'est notamment ce qu'étudient cécile
braconniers et jean-yves dorma gêne dans
leur livre la démocratie de l'abstention
où il étudie le cas de familles qui
avaient l'habitude d'aller voter tous
ensemble comme une espèce de tradition
familiale et qui se sont petit à petit
au cours du temps éloignés des urnes
troisièmement il y à l'action
rationnelle en valeur c'est quand j'ai
agi conformément à mes valeurs même si
ce n'est pas forcément rationnelle pour
mon bien-être par exemple un soldat qui
va combattre pour son pays il risque de
mourir mais il va quand même se battre
pour défendre son pays et donc ses
valeurs et dans le cas du vote on
comprend bien que si on est attaché aux
notions de démocratie ou de citoyenneté
c'est rationnel d'aller voter parce que
ça permet d'être conforme à ses valeurs
et enfin il y à la rationalité en
finalité est celle là c'est précisément
la rationalité froide étudié par les
économistes dont la conclusion logique
serait plutôt de ne pas aller voter sauf
si on pense que notre vote a des chances
d'être vraiment décisif
de ce projet et voilà c'est tout ce que
je voulais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui un l'idée c'était simplement
de montrer que certaines typologies à
ses anciennes comme celles des
différents modes d'action des beurs
pouvait être encore très utile pour
comprendre des phénomènes très
contemporain est aussi complexe que le
fait d'aller voter par exemple ça permet
aussi de montrer que le vote peut
s'étudier sous plusieurs angles est
précisément en sociologie on a plusieurs
paradigme différents qui ont tenté
d'expliquer le vote sans jamais épuisé
la complexité du sujet et justement
c'est là dessus que je vais revenir dans
les prochaines vidéos où je vais essayer
de faire un petit tour d'horizon des
grands paradigmes sociologique par
lesquels on a tenté d'expliquer le vote
et si vous êtes trop impatient pour
attendre l'épisode suivant je vous
rappelle que j'avais déjà fait une vidéo
sur le sujet il ya maintenant cinq ans
où je présentais le modèle dit
écologiste du précurseur andré-siegfried
je vous mettrais un lien quelque part si
la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
mettre un pouce vers le haut abonnez
vous mettez la cloche pour être au
courant des prochaines sorties et
surtout pas partager la vidéo 1 poule à
savoir au plus grand nombre et je
profite de cette fin de vidéo pour faire
une petite annonce si vous avez envie
d'en savoir plus sur la théorie du choix
rationnel et si par exemple vous
demander si monsieur spock prend
réellement toutes ces décisions de la
manière la plus rationnelle possible et
bien j'en parle justement dans un
chapitre du livre que je viens de
terminer et qui sort la semaine
prochaine ça s'appelle comprendre le
monde avec la pop culture c'est
disponible en précommande dans toutes
les bonnes plateformes ça sort mercredi
prochain et je refais une petite vidéo
très vite pour vous en parler en
attendant je vous fais de gros bisous à
très vite ciao
[Musique]